cette courtoisie se fait assez rare dans
le cinéma français mais je pense
notamment à pierre niney et gilles
lelouch dont le comportement en réseau
sur récents sur les réseaux sociaux
s'est révélée particulièrement odieux et
à jeter l'opprobre sur toute une
profession qui n'avait vraiment pas
besoin de ça peut-on faire un plan sur
eux s'il vous plaît merci alors je cite
pierre sur instagram ce connard de
gilles lellouche vraiment c'est comme ça
que vous parlez mon cher pierre oui je
suis désolé mais je le constate et vous
gilles je vous cite tu vas rester bien
assis sur ton p'tit cul et tu me diras
de quoi je re l'air sur scène ça c'est
bon esprit ah c'est ce qu'on appelle du
bon esprit moi je dis stop in the name
of love pierre et gilles la france vous
regarde faites vous un bisou maintenant
aller sinon je ne poursuit pas la
cérémonie et on ne saura jamais qui a
gagné le meilleur documentaire et c'est
dans ce monde là que vous avez envie de
vivre 1 allez-y moi j'ai tout mon temps
allez
réconciliation s'il vous plaît
voilà
voilà voilà on y est presque ça
s'approche oui elles seront ils un peu
sans les mains oui bah voila
voila merci merci messieurs on cède à
l'exemple et les films doublés pour le 6